llegó el momento para actualizar la
información económica en france 24 está
con nosotros pero jorge hurtado vamos a
empezar hablando de script o monedas
porque los principales ejecutivos de
este sector tuvieron una reunión y en el
congreso de eeuu así bueno se trata de
la primera reunión de un sector que
mueve más de 3.000 millones de dólares
en cripto activos con las autoridades de
eeuu los ejecutivos e instaron al
congreso a establecer normas más claras
para este sector aunque juana
advirtieron que normas demasiado
rigurosa los empujarían a irse del país
los principales ejecutivos de seis
grandes empresas de cripto monedas entre
ellas coin beige y zhirkov estuvieron
cara a cara con el comité de servicios
financieros de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu
varios analistas descartaron que el
congreso establezca nuevas normas sobre
escritos monedas a corto plazo ya que
según ellos los legisladores trataron la
audiencia principalmente como un
ejercicio de investigación y para
entender un poco más sobre este mundo
escuchemos parte del debate que se
desarrolló el día de hoy
por supuesto necesitamos normas de
circulación razonables lo sabemos no
necesitamos reacciones instintivas por
parte de los legisladores para regular
por miedo a lo desconocido en lugar de
buscar la comprensión y ese miedo a lo
desconocido y a la tendencia regular
antes de comprender solo ahogara el
ingenio estadounidense y nos pondrá en
desventaja competitiva
los estadounidenses merecen saber cuál
es nuestra política nacional para una
web descentralizada tratar el cripto
como una actividad cuya característica
principal es la necesidad de una
regulación financiera sería cómo tratar
el internet en la década de 1990 como
una cuestión de política fiscal
hemos hablado mucho de la caída de la
lira turca hoy hablo al respecto el
presidente recep tayyip erdogán y le
echó la culpa a los especuladores así es
bueno también le pidió a los turcos que
confíen en este nuevo modelo económico
que está tratando de impulsar en su país
el presidente de turquía erdogán aseguró
que el aumento de los precios es culpa
de oportunistas avaricioso y que
investigará lo que considera una
manipulación de la cotización de la lira
pero la caída de la lira es producto de
una agresiva relajación monetaria que
según economistas y opositores es parte
de una política económica imprudente la
inflación llegó el mes pasado ahí el
21.3 por ciento lo que provocó algunas
protestas la libra se debilitó un 2.6
por ciento frente al dólar antes de que
erdogán hablara en lo que va del año la
moneda ha perdido un 46 por ciento de su
valor frente a la moneda estadounidense
erdogán volvió a defender hoy su teoría
de que mantener los tipos de interés
bajos frena en la inflación aunque esta
teoría es contraria a la de la mayoría
de los economistas en el mundo hay una
reacción del presidente del banco
interamericano de desarrollo sobre el
impacto que podrían tener en la economía
de qué se trata bueno se trata de
mauricio claver el directivo del banco
interamericano de desarrollo que
considera que las vacunas contra el
joven 19 son el mayor éxito de la
historia de la colaboración
público-privada y un buen ejemplo a
seguir en latinoamérica
claver destacó que este tipo de
colaboraciones como las que surgieron
durante la pandemia son beneficiosas
para gobiernos empresas y ciudadanos
escuchemos un poco parte de su
explicación
de primer lugar veámoslo desde una
perspectiva macro estamos en un momento
de la historia en el que francamente la
única razón por la que salimos de esta
pandemia es pues la mayor colaboración
público-privada de la historia de la
humanidad que son las vacunas la forma
en que se crearon las vacunas gracias a
una histórica alianza público-privada
de la sociedad son transversales a este
respecto entonces el impacto de lo que
la innovación del sector privado y luego
obviamente el enfoque del sector público
en las necesidades de la población
traerá lo que respecta a la
adicionalidad desarrollo impacto
etcétera es la clave es que momento de
los indicadores económicos de la jornada
juana regamos con wall street que se
robó en positivo ya que los inversores
se vieron animados por las perspectivas
de que la variante o micro no sea tan
grave como se pensaba inicialmente las
acciones europeas cayeron por la
preocupación de la eficacia de las
vacunas existentes contra la variante o
micro y en américa latina la bolsa de
sao paulo cerró con cautela pendiente de
la decisión del banco central de brasil
sobre la tasa de los tipos de interés y
vamos con las cifras del día la cifra
tiene que ver con papel que está a un
paso de alcanzar los 3.000 millones de
dólares en capitalización bursátil esto
sería un hito que lo haría tan grande
como la quinta economía del mundo las
acciones de apple subieron un 1,6 por
ciento a 174 dólares pero necesita que
utilizará 182 dólares para alcanzar esta
marca histórica por geo muchísimas
gracias y gracias también como siempre
ustedes quédense en la pantalla de
france 24
[Música]